longues nuits longues discussions hier
au conseil national du parti socialiste
vous aussi merci d'être là malgré cette
nuit connu courte l'accord a donc été
validé à 62% vous étiez favorable à cet
accord vous êtes sur la ligne d'olivier
fort vous êtes soulagé ce matin oui
soulagé surtout soulagé parce que ce
sont nos électeurs qui je crois
attendait cet engagement des socialistes
dans cette nouvelle alliance dans ce
rassemblement de la gauche et des
écologistes sans exclusive quand il y à
90% des électeurs de gauche qui souhaite
le rassemblement est d'ailleurs on me
l'avait vu lors des élections
présidentielles s'étaient aussi cette
cette demande qui était fortement
exprimée et qui avait d'ailleurs
contribué à ce fort vote utile dès le
premier tour en forme en faveur de
jean-luc mélenchon donc oui je suis
soulagé y compris parce que disons le
c'est une forme de clarification les
électeurs de gauche ne savait plus
vraiment où se situait le parti
socialiste compte tenu de ce qui s'est
passé c'est des cinq dernières années
compte tenu ce qui s'était passé au
moment de l'élection présidentielle de
2017 et donc ce vote il signifie aussi
très clairement que le parti socialiste
est dans un camp celui de la gauche
c'était c'était vraiment nécessaire de
rappeler de rappeler que le ps était
vraiment de gauche à l'évidence à
l'évidence compte tenu à la fois des
incertitudes des parcours et compris
individuelle d'un certain nombre
d'anciens responsables du parti
socialiste quant au soir de l'élection
du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle vous n'avez aucun des
responsables du parti socialiste
d'aujourd'hui sur les plateaux de
télévision mais vous avez tous ceux
d'hier qui se promènent en expliquant
finalement qu'il fallait faire d'autres
choix qu'il fallait rejoindre les rives
de la macro ni je pensais me du helmand
est évidemment un manuel valls par
exemple eh bien ça trouble nos électeurs
ça fait ça ça entretient doute sur notre
identité politique et ce vote d'hier
soir eh bien il dit clairement ou non
[Musique]